[Music]
103 the number of murders if you add up
all the innocent people killed by serial
killers in mine hunter season 2 but what
did the show leave out who exactly are
these real-life killers join me as we
take a deep dive into the real-life
killers of mine hunter season 2 number
10
William Henry Hance four murders a
former marine turned army truck driver
hats began his rampage in 1978 all four
of his victims being women hands taunted
police by sending letters signed by the
forces of evil a fictitious group of
seven white vigilantes who threatened to
kill a black hostage if the stalking
strangler wasn't apprehended at the time
another series of murders were
threatening Georgia that of the stalking
strangler a man not featured in mine
hunter but was suspected of the deaths
of seven elderly white women pants used
these murders to divert attention away
from himself and his own brutal murders
two of the women he targeted were black
sex workers and two were army privates
although one of these murders he was
never charged with Robert Ressler one of
the FBI agents of which mine hunter is
based off was responsible for creating
Hans's psychological profile from the
letters and telephone calls he asserted
that the killer was one man not seven
black not white single uneducated and
likely a low ranking military man at the
fort in his late 20s this profile led
officers to stakeout nearby fort bars
once frequented predominantly by black
soldiers and were quickly able to
identify hence and arrest him wrestlers
profile had successfully narrowed down
the list of suspects hence was executed
via electric chair in 1994 number nine
David Berkowitz aka Son of Sam six
murders in the summer of 1976 the Son of
Sam killer terrorized the streets of New
York
city killing six and wounding seven
these murders according to Berkowitz
were spurred by a demon who had
manifested in his neighbor Sam's dog
Berkowitz taunted authorities by sending
letters that mocked police and promised
further crimes leading to the biggest
police manhunt in New York City history
he was later caught after a local
resident noticed a man watching her from
his car holding a quote dark object she
remembered that an officer had been
there earlier in the morning ticketing
cars police found that one of these cars
was Berkowitz's owned and in it they
found a duffel bag filled with
ammunition maps of the crime scenes and
a threatening letter addressed to
inspector Timothy Dowd of the Omega task
force as seen in the show Berkowitz
loved the attention the press gave him
which led the New York state legislature
to enact the Son of Sam laws designed to
keep criminals from profiting
financially from the publicity created
by their crimes in a press conference in
February of 1979 Berkowitz said his
previous claims of demonic possession
were a hoax in psychiatrist David
Abrahamson who was appointed Berkowitz
claimed Berkowitz had long contemplated
murder to get revenge on a world he felt
had rejected and hurt him Berkowitz
currently resides in the chou-heung
Correctional Facility in New York where
he goes by the name Sun of Hope after
becoming an evangelical Christian number
eight Paul Batterson seven murders
although only convicted of one murder
that of Addison barrel at gay film
critic for Variety magazine he is
suspected of six others in the 70s six
corpses of men had been found
dismembered in bags floating in the
Hudson River none of them have ever been
identified but police traced the clothes
on them to shops in Greenwich Village
that catered to the gay community the
banks reportedly had the words New York
University Medical Center's
neuropsychiatric unit and since
Patterson was a neurological technician
there he became a prime suspect but no
evidence was found linking him to the
crimes William Friedkin the director of
The Exorcist who had hired Batterson for
a role as a
Nishan in the movie later went on to say
Batterson had confessed to the unsolved
murders but those claims have not been
substantiated Batterson was released
from prison in 2003 and finished parole
in a 8 to this day it's unknown whether
he is still alive
number 7 Elmer Wayne Henley 7 murders
Henley was only 17 by the time he had
killed 7 people helping abduct over a
dozen more for a man by the name of Dean
Corll
between 1970 and 73 Henley brought
several young men some of them friends
of his to quarrel where the victims were
subjected to torture rape and their
eventual death Henley later brought
another young man and a 15 year old girl
to quarrel who was furious Henley would
bring a girl this altercation later
resulted in Coral goading Henley to
shoot him telling him he doesn't have
the guts to go through with it well
apparently he did because Henley shot
him set free the two victims and called
Pasadena police where he confessed to
the murders in court Henley was charged
for 6 murders his seventh that of Dean
Corll was deemed self-defense he
currently resides at the Mark Michel
prison in Anderson County Texas where
he's serving ninety nine years he's now
63 number six Charles Manson 7 murders
when I stand on the mountain and I say
do it it gets done if it don't get done
then I'll move on it and that's a last
thing in the world you want me to do
arguably the most notorious of the
killers on this list Charles Manson and
his followers committed a series of nine
murders seven of which he was convicted
for he created what would later be known
as the Manson Family a ragtag group of
predominantly women and adopted the term
helter skelter to describe an impending
apocalyptic race war these murders
according to the women would help
precipitate that war and Manson
allegedly told his followers to write
the words political piggy and draw a
black panther paw to frame the murders
as being done by the Black Panther
Manson as he does in the show disputes
this theory Tex Watson
who was responsible for carrying out the
infamous Sharon Tate murder said that
Manson was indeed trying to start a race
war but that the Tate murder was
designed to be a copycat crime to
exonerate Manson's friend Bobby
Beausoleil Manson was given the death
penalty for the role in the murders
which was later commuted to life in
prison without parole after the state of
California abolished the death penalty
he died of cardiac arrest in November
2017 at the age of 83 number 5 William
jr. Pierce 9 murders despite
psychologists considering him dangerous
William jr. Pierce was released on
parole in 1970 for a series of crimes in
the span of one year Pierce raped and
murdered an estimated nine people two
men and seven women his love for sweets
as depicted in the show came from actual
jail cell photographs and his permitted
items similar to that of a convenience
store he was known to have an IQ that
barely broke 70 and argued that his
confession was coerced after the sheriff
physically abused him by cutting his
privates he is currently 88 serving a
life sentence number 4 ed Kemper 10
murders why did you keep the heads why'd
you cut them off and why did you keep
something out of my childhood I could
put it on an incident I mean my father
chopping the heads off of our two pet
chickens and my mother insisting that I
eat him for dinner one of two returning
serial killers this season at Kemper
also known as the co-ed killer embarked
on a murder spree from 1972 to 1973 he
got the nickname co-ed killer because of
his affinity for picking up female
students who were hitchhiking he gained
notoriety for several reasons his
stature
six foot nine high intellect an IQ of
145 and the fact he would dismember his
victims and perform a room a show on
their severed heads as a teen he killed
his grandmother and grandfather and was
diagnosed as a paranoid schizophrenic at
the end of his killing spree he would
later go on to kill his
mother an event that spurred him to call
the police and confess to her murder but
shockingly enough the police didn't
believe him and told him to call back at
a later time it was only when he called
an officer that he personally knew that
he was brought in and confessed to the
other murders saying that emotionally he
couldn't handle it anymore in custody he
tried to commit suicide twice but failed
he currently resides at the California
medical facility an all-male state
prison where he served seven years to
life for each of his murders number 3
Dennis Rader 10 murders
I have many of what I called him
projects there were different people in
the town that I followed watch captain
Bryant was just driving by one day and I
saw her go in the house with somebody
else
that's a possibility Rader also known as
the BTK strangler BTK short for bind
torture and kill is arguably minehunters
most mysterious killer from 1974 to 1991
Rader committed 10 murders in the Metro
Wichita Kansas area but what makes him
so fascinating is his motive of sexual
sadism and like Berkowitz his taunting
letters to police Rader seemingly lived
a double life on one hand a devout
church-going family man while on the
other a murderous sexual deviant he was
also elected president of his church's
council his spree began in 1974 with the
murder of 4 members of the Otero family
a murder which is recounted in mine
hunter by one of these survivors Kevin
bright he would later get more brazen
even bringing one of his victims to his
church where he photographed her body in
various bondage positions in 2005 Rader
sent a letter to police asking if he
were to send a floppy disk
could it be traced the police responded
in a newspaper ad in the Wichita Eagle
saying it would be safe this was alive
in a stupid move for someone who
considered himself a criminal mastermind
Rader sent a floppy disk to the police
but unbeknownst to him the police were
able to recover metadata
which contained the words Christ
Lutheran Church and that the document on
the disk was last modified by someone
named Dennis the president of the Church
Council Rader was apprehended in
February of 2005 where he was sentenced
to 10 consecutive life sentences with a
minimum of a hundred and seventy-five
years he currently resides at the
Eldorado Correctional Facility in Butler
County Kansas where he lives in solitary
confinement allowed one hour of exercise
a day and three showers a week number
two Wayne Bertram Williams 24 murders
although only convicted of two murders
22 others of the 28 Atlanta murders of
79 to 81 have been attributed to
Bertrand's an aspiring music manager
Bertram is alleged to have lured young
boys and strangle them to death his
conviction however was for the murder of
two adult men in which hairs and fibers
from Williams's home car and dog matched
with the victims like the show depicts
Williams was first considered a suspect
after police staking out a bridge along
the Chattahoochee River heard a splash
followed by his car crossing the bridge
he told police he was checking on an
address of a potential singer the number
he gave police turning out to be
fictitious to this day Williams
maintains his innocence and a request
for a retrial in 2006 was denied by a
federal judge Williams lawyers argued
that the carpet fibers used to implicate
him in the crimes wouldn't hold up to
scientific scrutiny and that the police
department covered up evidence that
showed the Ku Klux Klan was involved
Williams is currently 61 serving life at
the Telfair state prison in Georgia
number 1 Dean Corll 28 Plus murders
although only mentioned through the
interview with Elmer Wayne Henley in the
show Dean Corll is the serial killer
with the highest kill count from 1970 to
73 coral abducted raped and tortured
over 28 teenage boys and young men and
what would be known as the Houston mass
murders coral used to accomplish
mrs. David Owen Brooks and Elmer Wayne
Henley to lure young men to his place
with a promise of drugs and alcohol
once impaired he tied them to Iraq and
subject his victims to unimaginable
torture quarrel was known as the
Candyman killer because his family owned
and operated a candy factory in Houston
Heights he had also been known to give
free candy to local children quarrels
death at the hands of Elmer Henley
marked the end of the Houston murders
Henley later showed police where the
bodies were buried 17 at a rented boat
shed six on a beach near Bulevar
Peninsula four near Lake Sam Rayburn and
one on another beach in Jefferson County
coral currently serves an eternity in
hell without parole that's it for this
list of the real life killers of
minehunters season two please make sure
to LIKE comment and subscribe and if you
haven't checked out my other video on
mine hunter season 2 make sure to give
it a look you can also follow me on
twitter at things story whitey and
remember daddy loves you very much